The Mandalorian's second season has really
put Din Djarin through the wringer.
In addition to fighting a krayt dragon and
one horde after the next of enemies, he's
also had his entire belief system questioned
upon learning he's actually a Child of the
Watch, an extremist sect of Mandalorians who
aim to reestablish the ancient order of their
kind.
Part of their creed involves never removing
one's helmet, which Din has stuck to.
There have only been two times so far in the
series when we've seen Din's face.
The first comes when he suffers injuries and
has to remove his helmet for treatment, only
revealing his face to an unliving droid (voiced
by Taika Waititi.
The second time occurs in Chapter 15, when
Din has to gain access to sensitive materials
from the Empire by showing his face.
It appears as though Din is questioning his
belief system more and more in recent episodes,
and even though he's still hesitant to remove
his helmet, he's willing to do so if it means
saving Grogu.
Rumors have been circling that the reason
for these increasingly common face reveals
lies in Pedro Pascal wanting more facetime
on the Star Wars series.
Some rumors even extend to the point of saying
Pascal would leave the show if he continued
being hidden behind all that beskar all the
time.
In a recent television appearance, he laid
those rumors to rest and assured fans that
he's perfectly happy doing what's best for
the show.
Audiences will be able to see Pedro Pascal's
face front and center in the upcoming superhero
sequel Wonder Woman 1984 as the villainous
Maxwell Lord.
As such, he's been doing a whole lot of media
appearances in promotion of the film.
When he called in virtually on The One Show,
the topic shifted to his work on The Mandalorian.
He was asked point-blank about the rumors
that purport he wants his helmet off more
often.
Pascal was quick to deny them.
After saying the rumors aren't true, he went
on to state,
"It's a really wonderful way of telling the
story.
It's always been a very clear creed for the
character and the collaborative process of
the whole thing, we've all been on the same
page with this.
So what I want is for them to make the best
show possible, however they get that done."
It sounds as though Pascal understands why
the creative forces behind the show want Din
Djarin's helmet on, and he's totally cool
with going along for the ride and performing
however is best for the character.
It's clear how deeply the character believes
in the Mandalorian creed, and when he takes
off his helmet in Chapter 15, it is obvious
how uncomfortable it makes him.
Perhaps he'll open up more in the future,
when more circumstances arise that require
him to reveal himself.
By all accounts, Pascal will be portraying
Din Djarin for quite some time to come.
Disney has announced The Mandalorian will
return for season three sometime in December
2021 (via Collider).
During the recent Disney Investor Day event,
the company announced a slew of Star Wars
projects, including two that will take place
at the same time as the events of The Mandalorian:
An Ahsoka Tano series and Rangers of the New
Republic.
All of these shows will cross over in a big
climactic event, so it's within the realm
of possibility that Din might show up on these
other series as well.
With plenty more adventures coming down the
pipeline, it's likely we're going to see Din
Djarin continue to wrestle with what he has
learned from Bo-Katan Kryze and the Nite Owls.
Other Mandalorians are out there, and they
don't necessarily believe in the same things
he does.
Instead, they're out there trying to regain
their homeworld, and the day may come when
the Nite Owls require his assistance for a
certain job.
While Din's still not completely comfortable
taking his helmet off, he may get more comfortable
with the idea if he gets the chance to spend
more time with a different sect of Mandalorians
who aren't as strict with the rules as he
is.
You can see Pedro Pascal next when the final
episode of The Mandalorian season two airs
on Disney+ on December 18th, 2020.
A week later, on December 25th, you can see
him again over on HBO Max and in theaters
(where they're open) in Wonder Woman 1984.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.